cool hat thanks Mary
I'm smiling that's a bad hair day Ashley
okay no it's my hat let me wear it I'll
stop it's mine let me wear it just for a
second it's mine that's why Adam having
a bad hair day amanecer me it's money
that's why I'm wearing it it is his hat
we gotta do what you most want to know
why well you ate my cereal you use my
shampoo and you [ __ ] on the carpet we're
gonna [ __ ] on the carpet well I did [ __ ]
on the carpet
okay I [ __ ] on the carpet but I'm sure
mine just focus a little top of it and
you always ask us to tickle you and it
honestly it makes me feel awful articles
you too yeah there's a lot to go check
on makes me feel a little weird I'm not
sure man laughing keep touching my
French cities and I told you when they
come over stop oh you see America amount
of clothes we're out of it almost okay
what are you wired from their phone we
already packed your bags oh I'm never
gonna go get my real time to go
[Music]
we should get that door - yeah
[Music]
are you looking at me see what are you
doing Oh something's in my eye
oh no I'm sorry sweetie my reps movie
tonight yeah sure also my best friend
famous
[Music]
[Applause]
hey guys it's me Amanda Cerny thank you
so much for watching my turning skits
and liking and commenting
I literally read every single one of
them so thank you guys since journey is
growing and I love it
I want to involve you guys even more so
what I'm doing now is I'm taking
journeys get suggestion ideas that Ames
you just comment below and these good
ideas that you have from me and if I
decide to choose your idea that will
shout you out in my next journey skit
YouTube video so keep the comments
coming and is enough it could be you
love you guys and I'll see you next week
thankful